how does netflix's vikings valhalla
relate to the original history series is
the same creative team making the sequel
will it be historically accurate keep
watching for all those answers and a lot
more
just when you thought you had a handle
on all the various descendants relatives
and acquaintances of ragnar lothbrok the
story of valhalla jumps more than 100
years into the future according to a
netflix press packet the sequel series
begins in the year 1002 kicking off with
a particular historical event that could
be the viking attack on london bridge
led by olaf haroldson in the trailer but
historically that event didn't take
place until several years later if it
happened at all so it's more likely
something else another candidate is the
saint bryce's day massacre in which king
aethelred ii ordered the slaughter of
all the danish vikings living in english
territory hoping to put an end to years
of viking raids instead king aethelred's
actions provoked the danish king's swain
fork beard to increase the frequency and
severity of his attacks eventually
forcing aethered and his queen emma of
normandy into exile considering many of
the main players in the saint price's
day massacre are confirmed characters
for the first season of vikings valhalla
seems like a strong dramatic contender
to kick off the series the entire north
is threatened
by the english king whatever event marks
the beginning of vikings valhalla
prepare to see a significantly more
complex political landscape than in
vikings in the netflix press package
showrunner jeb stewart explains what the
world will look like the vikings had
been living in the british isles and it
settled into big areas called the
danelaw the dane law had started to grow
not just with danes but also with swedes
and norwegians and folks from all over
scandinavia saxon nobles were afraid
that if you went out another generation
suddenly there wouldn't be any
difference between saxons and vikings
the vikings on vikings spent most of
their time engaged in power struggles
but there was one man in control behind
the camera creator michael hearst wrote
every single episode of vikings so
perhaps it's not surprising that he'll
be less involved in the sequel series
first will still be an executive
producer alongside vikings vets morgan
o'sullivan and showrunner jeff stewart
stewart stuart giumeno is one of the
co-writers of die hard
given the time jump we likely won't be
seeing any of the familiar faces from
vikings unless they appear as ghosts
visions or in flashbacks fortunately the
same person who worked his casting magic
for vikings is back for valhalla frank
boyzell returns as casting director and
has filled the new series with cast
members of sullivan says bring a fresh
youthful energy to this story also back
is viking's historical consultant justin
pollard he will be the one digging into
the obscure history being explored by
the show working to make sure it's as
accurate as possible he spent months
consulting with stewart on the new
series before writing even started as
for the shooting location viking's
valhalla is being shot in ireland just
like the original series so there will
be the same breathtaking scenery fans
expect to see
vikings had one indisputable lead
character ragnar lothbrok vikings
valhalla though will have three central
characters sharing the spotlight
legendary viking explorer leif erikson
pagan shieldmaiden freitas eric's
daughter and the norwegian prince and
viking berserker harold sigurdsson
brother and sister leif and freitas will
meet harold for the first time during
the events of the series stewart says he
chose to build the story around these
three characters because of what they
represent in the netflix press kit he
says for me they each embody different
elements of the viking spirit bringing
leif and freitas who were both
greenlanders to norway to categort and
embedding them in the viking story just
seemed a very natural place to go
centering vikings valhalla around three
characters will also help offer a
broader perspective on the culture and
characters which will be important to
help modern viewers relate to the story
stuart added it's a timeless story in a
strange way if you take massive violence
out of the equation the vikings embody
some of the elements that we still most
want for ourselves our characters are
dealing with relationships and issues
that are just as relevant today as they
were a thousand years ago and those
stories will always excite and captivate
us
while some suspected that the title
vikings valhalla meant a glimpse into
the viking afterlife we now know that
the title of the series isn't
necessarily about that sort of life
after death the title valhalla was
chosen because the show depicts the
events that lead to the end of the
viking age which historically ended in
1066. stewart said we played with a lot
of new titles and kept coming back to
valhalla because the idea of the show is
inherently tied to the end of this era
it's all about showing this incredible
time in history and how all things
eventually come to an end but don't get
too worried just yet about the end of
the vikings era since the series begins
in 1002 the show has more than six
decades to play around with before the
viking age comes to a historical close
and it's not like any period of history
ever came to a neat stop so we wouldn't
worry about running out of viking
legends to dramatize anytime soon
preda gustavsson will be playing freitas
eric's daughter the daughter of eric the
red and sister of leif erikson on
valhalla in an uncanny coincidence
gustav sen's real-life father is also
named eric and her real-life brother is
also named leif and it doesn't end there
gustav's real-life nickname is also
freitas i wonder she really threw
herself into the role reading multiple
books to prepare with her favorite being
valkyrie the women of the viking world
gustavson was also an accomplished
writer prior to the show giving her an
advantage during the scenes on horseback
we can only hope she also did some
strength training too since gustav since
costume is actually the heaviest of all
the lead characters on the show there
are more than 2 700 hand-cut leaves that
decorate her shield maiden armor
a big part of bringing the characters to
life on vikings was the intricate
costumes designed in the show's final
few seasons by costume designer susan
o'connor cave cave is back for vikings
valhalla using her keen eye for detail
to enhance the story for example while
the high neck dresses that emma of
normandy wears on the show are
indicative of her station and royal
bearing they're also meant to act as her
armor they convey that although she
doesn't charge into battle like a shield
maiden she's still a warrior in her own
right similarly although the devout yarl
kora holds no official position in the
church the silhouette of his costume is
meant to evoke a cassock a garment
traditionally worn by certain christian
clergy cave also incorporated the
viking's cultural and religious shifts
into her costume designs for vikings
valhalla you may notice richer colors
and more chainmail in the vikings
costumes meant to reflect their
transition to christianity color and
texture also play a big role in
enhancing the characters with the
greenlanders costumes meant to reflect
their connection to the earth and the
vikings costumes overall appearing more
organic favoring wolves linens and furs
the saxons meanwhile will wear mostly
velvets silks and brocades with heavy
embellishments highlighting the stark
differences between the cultures
while vikings developed a reputation for
playing a bit fast and loose with
history the truth is a bit more
complicated than that justin pollard
served as historical consultant on both
vikings and vikings valhalla making him
responsible for all the research that
helped inform the story lines but
researching viking history isn't as
simple as just referencing old texts as
jeb stewart explained in his netflix
interview there are a million different
ways to look at history we don't know a
whole lot about the original vikings
they didn't have a written language so
the documentation is tricky they left us
the sagas but the sagas were written 200
years after the end of the story and
they were written by christians we know
archaeologically what has been dug up
but we're still discovering new things
about viking culture obviously it's
tricky to make an authentic show about a
group of people whose history was only
written down centuries after the fact
and even then only by people outside
their culture there's no simple correct
version to defer to which means that
many creative decisions are based on
historical interpretations rather than
historical facts still the team behind
vikings valhalla did their best to be as
true to history as they could steward
says ultimately we've made an authentic
show sometimes we've moved dates or
characters around a bit but the
historical pieces are all there
while things did begin to shift by the
end of the series the original vikings
mostly pitted the pagan vikings against
the english christians with only
isolated characters like athelstan
expressing any interest in bridging that
gap however the series does feature the
conversion of the viking warrior rolo to
christianity at first in name only but
later on in practice a hundred years
later the religious landscape in europe
looked very different with many vikings
having followed in rollo's footsteps and
converted to christianity vikings
valhalla will explore the conflict
between the pagan and christian vikings
with both sides being well represented
by the viking families in the series of
its three main characters freitas and
leif will both still worship odin and
the old gods while harold is a christian
more broadly while the greenlander
vikings will still be pagan the
norwegian and danish vikings will have
largely converted to christianity
according to stewart the two groups will
clash in vikings valhalla in a religious
civil war christians are my true enemy
and you are mine he said in the netflix
press kit it's a long and somewhat
complex timeline but when our story is
set christian vikings were mostly very
sincere very tough and very focused on
absolute and total conversion to
christianity or violently wiping
paganism off the map entirely
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]